in the middle
please stand for the chairman of Sunny
District Council
previous easy members
[Music]
ah all right
[Applause]
good evening members and north of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council and uh just before I press
on with the usual announcement I'd like
to thank councilor cupp very much for
going around to the station for me
as it turned out it wasn't necessary but
thank you councilor cup
thank you
so pressing on with the usual
announcements if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the officer's
fire the stairs either through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer please do not use
the lifts please assemble in holy Square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
with respect to filming off the meeting
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the me
public areas may have their image
captured therefore I urge anyone filming
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
children present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening
I don't see any indications as such any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information
is considered following exclusion the
press and public from the meeting
with respect to the Restriction of the
use of mobile phones would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls during the meeting and do
forgive me I'm just about to do that
with mine now
foreign
it's off now
I've been rushed around quite a bit so
right agenda item one apologies for
absence I have received apologies from
counters rossecky day ference and
Portmore are there any other apologies
this evening yeah
who forgot
cancer common cooking Council of
Beverage
get on those down
do I have any other apologies this
evening
councilor Garner councilor Gregory
do I have any other apologies
councilor ARA councilor Ara
councilor Piper councilor Linda Potts
chairman
lovely
we've got all those marked down thank
you very much indeed
gender item two announcements I've not
been informed of any announcements
inclined to give a few myself but uh not
this evening gender item three
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest this evening
I didn't see any indications agenda item
four minutes of the previous meeting I
moved at the minutes of the meeting of
council held on the 9th of February 2023
be approved and signed as a correct
record with Vice chaply second second
that chair do members agree
thank you
a gen agenda item five petitions
no new petitions have been received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
12.
therefore Moving Straight on to agenda
item six that is questions from the
press and public
there have been three questions received
from the press and public and in
accordance with Council procedure rule
number 13.
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question
good question now please only state the
name of the cabinet member to whom the
question is to be put and read out the
exact wording of the question that they
submitted to the council
so moving on to agenda item 6A question
number one from a member of the public
regarding Street cleansing
I am therefore pleased to welcome Miss
bright to the meeting Miss bright would
you like to make your way to the
microphone please
thank you this is a question for
councilor cup
the absence of a street cleaner in
Beacon Road Ward is evident residents
complain of paths covered in leaf mulch
broken glass and dog waste that can make
simple Journeys hazardous
especially for those with mobility
issues
street cleaners are visible in more
commercial areas but we need them in
residential areas too it's not right
that people are forced to walk in the
roads because Pavements have not been
cleaned
furthermore the removal of dog waste
bins next to our Alleyways has meant
piles of dog waste bags have been left
where the bins once were
what plans do the council have to
urgently clean up the streets in my ward
to ensure our residents are able to walk
around safely thank you thank you very
much indeed Miss bright I believe
actually this question is for Council
bayford to answer councilor Beaufort yep
thank you thank you for that and thank
you Mr bright for your question but last
year we introduced the zonal system for
our street cleaning service which most
people feel has led to an improvement in
the standard of cleaner streets I'm
sorry if you feel that this Improvement
has not been felt in Beacon roadhold
we're currently exploring the
opportunity for an online reporting tool
which will allow members of the public
the ability to directly report areas of
concern regarding litter environmental
operatives could then be deployed within
a reasonable time frame as dictated by
the footfall intensity of that area this
would allow us to manage resources more
effectively and allow the public to draw
areas of concern to the council's
attention this will also identify any
scheduled issues in the meantime we will
continue to manage resources in the most
effective one Manner and respond to
reports as they are received currently
this does mean focusing on the high
football areas of the district such as
Town centers
it should be noted that we are presently
publishing our street cleaning service
standards which advises residents of the
service they can expect to receive
with regard to bins we are undertaking
review of our bin provision across the
district this includes the removal of
dog bins in some places and the
introduction of litter bins where
required were alternatively assigned to
the next available bin within reasonable
walking distance
I would point out that dog waste can be
put in general waste bins but I have to
say though I find it hard to understand
why people leave bags of dog waste where
have been used to be
thank you very much indeed councilor
bayford
gender item 6B question number two from
a member of the public regarding the
recent calls for site sites I'm
therefore pleased to welcome Mr Woodward
to the meeting Mr Woodward could you
please make your way to the microphone
thank you chair thank you for the
opportunity to ask this question uh the
question is with the Isle of thanet's
top quality food producing farmland and
a catastrophic threat from over
development why did fannet District
Council decide to continue activity with
a second call for sites whilst the local
plan was paused thank you thank you Mr
Woodward I call upon the leader
councilor Ashby
I was prepared in accordance with the
government guidance
it was agreed by two independent
inspectors the guidance has not changed
and neither has the housing standard
method however the government has
published and proposed amendments to the
National planning policy framework and
has indicated its intention to review
the standard method in 2024
the council will be responding to the
current
government government's consultation on
a number of key points including the
greater Clarity should be given to the
government's position on the status of
best the most versatile agricultural
land
the proposed word in relation to
agricultural land is very vague and
should be strengthened
the local Plan update has been delayed
in terms of making any formal decision
in react relation to the local plan
including housing land and other
policies this is because the council is
waiting for the government to provide
Clarity on potential future housing
requirements and the status of best most
versatile farmland and other matters
the level of housing requirement informs
many
important decisions in the local plan
and until there is Clarity on this
matter it is difficult to move the plan
forward however the call for sites
process is an integral part of the
ongoing review
thank you very much indeed leader
gender item 6C question number three
from a member of the public regarding
the leveling up and regeneration Bill
I'm therefore pleased to welcome Miss
McCourt to the meeting Ms McCourt could
you please make your way to the
microphone
hello this is a question to councilor
Ashby again
my question is in light of the current
consultation regarding the leveling up
and regeneration Bill reforms to
National planning policy part of the
reforms include the need to quote make
sure that food security considerations
are factored into planning decisions
that affect Farmland how does TDC intend
to address this issue now rather than
wait for government responses to
correspondence already sent which does
not even address the issue of us losing
our local farmland
thank you thank you Ms McCall I call
upon the leader councilor Ashby to
respond thank you chairman
's ass
the council will be responding to the
current government consultation and a
number of key points including greater
Clarity should it be given to the
government's position on the status of
best and most versatile agricultural
land
the proposed wording in relation to
agricultural land is very vague and it
should be strengthened however until the
changes are made to the mppf the council
must adhere to the government guidance
as it currently exists in both plan
making and decisions on planning
applications this does not provide an
opportunity to rewrite the provisions of
existing plans in the meantime the
council need to continue to to consent
housing on the site allocated in the
doctor in the adopted plan subject to
the detailed schemes being acceptable
refusing applications on allocated sites
would likely lead to those consents
being issued on appeal with the risk of
significant costs being awarded against
the council
thank you very much indeed leader
that concludes questions from the public
so therefore moving on to agenda item
seven questions from members of the
council now I've had six questions this
evening from members of the council
please note the time allowed for
consideration of questions from Members
shall not exceed 30 minutes
we usually all pretty succincts I'm sure
that won't happen I asked Mummers to be
as succinct as possible gender item 7i a
therefore question number one from a
member regarding a recycling bins in
Open Spaces I call upon counselor Roth
councilor off
thank you chair this question is from
the young children from my work and I
must say I'll stick to the question but
it was sent in December missed a
deadline by one hour that's why that may
regard
as it is
as is now the summons finish
can the council consider to move some of
a recycling bin from the seafront to the
park and Open Spaces this question spoke
councilor Beckford and I must say I have
noticed some overbeans recycling bin has
been put in some parks but the park I'm
referring to is a rugby ground with
youth Community Club
thank you thank you councilor Council
bayford
thank you chairman thank you Council
Wolfe
um I mean you're right you did get
caught up in the the sort of Hassle and
kind of missed the moment in a way but I
can say that
um we didn't deliberately relocate any
binge from seafront to Open Spaces but
in preparation for the forthcoming
summer season we are undertaking a full
review of our bin provision
this will include recycling bins once
this is completed we'll have a better
understanding of the full requirement
however in the meantime we do have plans
to roll out an additional 20 standard
size recycling bins as part of a wider
investment in Street cleansing
the intention then would be to increase
by further 20 bins the provision in 2425
and this could include putting bins in
some of the parks and Open Spaces if the
capacity presents itself sooner we will
Flex the resource accordingly
thank you councilor bayford councilor
off do you have a supplementary question
yeah thank you thank you Council Bay for
for that answer my supplementary
question is this is then have been told
they need to have public liability if
they wish to organize a letter picking
event that's not for individual
individuals can go out and do letter
picking what council have in planned or
in place to help those they wish to to
cleanse Alleyways or string thank you
thanks for the councilor off an
interesting one for you councilor
bayford
I think it's interesting in fact I don't
think it relates to the actual question
so therefore I think it's inadmissible
but having said that I mean we obviously
do support Volunteers in the work they
do it's very vital in some places you
know the area is very much improved and
so we appreciate what they do I'm afraid
I can't give you any I I don't know the
answer to public liability situation but
I can find out and I can give you a
written answer
thank you councilor bayford gender item
7B question number two from remember
regarding the development of Western
Undercliff and the Western Undercliff
Paul sites
a goal account councilor Wing thank you
chair the Western the old western
Undercliff Cafe and Westcliff Hall sites
remain a blight on the town of Ramsgate
since they were sold at auction a number
of years ago plans for the Western
Undercliff Cafe were approved some time
back and the last information concerning
the Westcliffe Hall again a number of
years ago was that there has been some
pre-application talks with the TDC
planning please could we have an update
on where these developments are at
thank you very much counselor ring
councilor Pugh believe you're going to
respond to this
hi I'm chair and thank you councilor
wing for your question
details of all plan applications are
published on the council's website
including information about whether they
are approved or rejected the application
for the Western Undercliff Cafe for the
erection of a five-story building
comprising of a calf with outdoor
seating area public toilets refuse cycle
store at ground level and eight Flats at
the first second and third floor level
and a restaurant at the fourth floor
level was approved on the 30th November
2020. the consent is valid for three
years and must be started within that
time
there are two pre-commencement
conditions attached to the consent and
both were just discharged in April 2021
this means that under planning
legislation development could commence
at any time the council's also agreed
heads of terms with the owner in respect
of oversailing Rights over the adjacent
public footpath
there is currently no application for
refurbishment or conversion of the West
Cliff Hall but once a valid application
is received details will be published on
the council's website
thank you for that Council Pugh Council
Wayne do you have a supplementary
uh Paul as our number of residents we
and I
read the structure of the road and we
know that the the whole whole that
that's the structure holds up the side
of the road could I ask that that we
actually send somebody out from TDC
probably building control to actually
check that that structure is is okay
because when it went to auction there
were issues with that structure so given
the road is is deteriorating there are
concerns that the structure is also
deteriorating thank you
thank you counseling South sensible
Council Pugh
thank you chair I'm not sure I could
respond now that you've said it's
sensible
um but now I'll do my best uh counseling
I think let's take that away uh let's
speak to officers and let's see what we
can do
um you know and we can discuss it
further so yeah
thank you councilor cool agenda item 7c
question number three from a member
regarding consultation with the nppf
I called upon councilor Scott
thank you chair
um I believe this is a question to our
leader um and it is follows our planet
District Council going to respond to the
nppf consultation and when will you
publish the response thank you
thank you councilor Scott
Council Ashby
thank you thank you
um
for the fear of repeating myself today I
think I probably will be having through
this because there's obviously a lot of
interest in this and I just wish that
the government would issue papers that
everybody could understand and we'd all
know a clear path forward but
unfortunately they haven't done but
there's something that we can work on
the consultation deadline is the 2nd of
March and it is the intention of this
Council to respond on a number of key
points including the review of the
housing standard method should be
brought forward and any new methodology
should be evidence-based and related to
the emerging census data that is
important to remember that because the
census only just come out and I think
the government probably don't realize
the results are out if they do they
haven't probably read it and yes I am
criticizing my own government this
greater Clarity should be provided on
what factors might mitigate the housing
requirements in any given area the
indications are that we probably don't
need the numbers that were originally
set about but until we start to
challenge it and dig down deep into it
then there will be a problem the greater
Clarity should be given to the
government's position on the status of
best and most versatile agricultural
land and I think this is the key point
to remember here especially in thanet
because we obviously have got grade 1
one agricultural land here and it's
definitely something that we can
highlight them and push on the intention
is to publish the council's response
following submission
thank you leader and it sounded pretty
thorough too councilor Scott do you have
a supplementary
yes I do thank you uh thanks for the
response um basically
probably are going to repeat yourself
but it's a bit of a follow-up has the
TDC local plan Review Committee
discussed and considered the mppf
regarding sustainability for existing
communities and future Generations
thank you councilor Scott leader
response yes thank you um we don't
actually have a Review Committee what we
do have is a
coach eye chair and is supported by the
um Shadow leader and other
um interested parties across parties
um what I would say is that following
the paper coming out officers planning
officers were asked on my behalf to
decode
the the writings of the government to
which they did in a very comprehensive
report unfortunately what he does
highlight is is that there are a lot of
ambiguous
items uh areas in it and there is also
some very vague items the one that I do
think they probably shot their foot in
uh shot them in themselves in the foot
is the is this particular part about the
assessment of agricultural land
so I will read it for clarity and I hope
you can apply it to the further
questions that are coming forward on the
same subject the love consultation
document indicates that the government
is proposing to change to the current
wording the current wording of the mppf
by stating that consideration should be
given to the relative value of
agricultural land for food production
where significant development of higher
or quality agricultural land is
demonstrated to be necessary compared to
areas of poorer quality land so on that
basis my proposal is and what we will be
pushing for very very hard is for the
government to stop building on grade one
agricultural land and we will push that
right the way forward until
um till the election so and
[Applause]
um
because they they put it in such a vague
way I actually feel it's easier for us
to attack so I have been pushing as you
know a long time along with um sir Roger
Gale on all of the issues regarding
numbers we wrote a comprehensive paper
it was sent to the ministry
um the housing minister of which we've
had six in the last 12 months so it was
I'm not sure they passed it round
whereas as they went round the revolving
door but um certainly is number one
priority for me
um coming from family uh Pharma farming
family it is important so that's we need
to push and be specific on that one
point and I think that going forward we
can't do much about what's happened in
the past but we certainly can do much
about what's happening in the future
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed leader we
went over our two minutes but I don't
think any of us minded because we had
such a thorough answer
agenda item 70 question number four from
a seasoned campaigner here remember
regarding the lifts in Ramsgate Royal
Harbor car park I call upon counselor
Everett
thank you Joe I won't take advantage of
your leniency over time on this occasion
but I might store it up for future use
um
question for councilor Saunders we all
agreed a fortnight ago that the state of
ramsgate's Royal Harbor car park is
disgusting can I tonight press the
cabinet member on the question of
whether the lack of working lifts is
dangerous
what is his advice to customers unable
to navigate the stairs for physical or
practical reasons but who cannot find a
space to park on the ground floor is he
confident that the present Arrangements
which require them to use the vehicle
ramps to move between floors are safe
and if not what's he doing about it
thank you very much indeed Council
Edward I do like to show latitude when
it comes to the time for questions
because if the sake of democracy uh
councilor Saunders would you care to
respond
I certainly would chairman and thank you
councilor Everett for your question
which is structured in three parts as I
read it each appearing to require a
personal response from myself as a
Cabinet holder
so on the first part where the list lift
being out of action is dangerous my
personal opinion is that the lift is
lift not working sorry the lift not
working is certainly and I've
experienced it myself it's an
inconvenience but I'm not sure and I
wouldn't say that it's dangerous in
itself
well I would say and again this is my
opinion is that multi-story car Parks
can be very challenging and I accept
that they're usually compact in design
requiring tight corners and blind spots
inevitably Etc which is why many users
would prefer to use an open car park but
I wouldn't say that they are inherently
dangerous
on the second part which asked me what
is my advice to customers unable to
navigate the stairs who can't park on
the ground floor well quite honestly
councilor Everett without knowing the
personal circumstances in each case I'm
unable to respond or give advice to that
situation well it can confirm and I
found this out
surprisingly for myself and I should
have known it previously being
responsible for parking is that within
the Royal Harbor car park there are 22
disabled bays and eight parent and child
bays located on the ground floor as well
as the annex area which has also got
ground floor access
on the third part is the
am I confident that the present
arrangements are safe
firstly can I say that the use of
vehicle access ramps by pedestrians to
exit via or access higher floors is
never recommended or encouraged notices
were placed at the entrance and
strategically elsewhere within the car
park regarding the lifts following
previous discussions with the wall
councilors
and these notices and I visited the car
park myself today these notices have
been refreshed following the recent
council meeting
comments were made at the last council
meeting as you refer to them regarding
the condition of the car park and I can
confirm that the annual deep clean is
due to take place during and before the
end of March
also and as councils have expressed
concern regarding this car park
consideration is being given to whether
officers should be asked to undertake an
assessment of whether or not whether or
not the car park needs to be temporary
closed in addition to the issue
regarding the lifts this may be
necessary anyway because I understand
that we have an issue regarding free
running with youths using the the
multi-story car park to access other
areas external to the car park and
understand that on one instance there
was a person actually used the car park
to access the roof of a passing bus
thank you
thank you councilor Saunders what you're
saying is that you can't put yourself in
danger from a lift that doesn't work
absolutely right
I call upon counselor Everett for
supplementary well I thank cancer
soldiers for his reply but of course the
point is that because the lifts don't
work people are using the vehicle ramps
um I've not personally persuaded that
the signage that's been provided has
been adequate and of course people could
be pointed in the direction of
Staffordshire Street Car Park which is
all on one level and doesn't require
e-lifts what would be more helpful of
course is if the cabinet member could
advise us when the council might get
around to fixing the lifts given that
they've had 332 000 pounds in its budget
for three years and has shown no
progress towards that can he tell us
whether there's any Prospect of the
lifts being fixed in the near future
thank you Council Everett councilor
Saunders unfortunately I've had no
update regarding the lifts
um I would like to see him obviously
repaired as soon as possible but you do
mention that the fact that that money's
been there for three years and this
Administration has not been responsible
for all of that time
um but I will do as much as I can to put
some pressure on it uh as far as the
notices are concerned
um yes I visited myself they have been
refreshed uh I think I need to review
the wording you're absolutely right
there needs to be reference to
Alternative arrangements and I'll do my
best to get those notices updated and
reviews as soon as possible thank you
thank you councilor Saunders agenda item
7A question number five from a member
regarding the local plan and housing
numbers I call upon councilor Braidwood
thank you chair my question is for
councilor Ashby
planet's local plan has been written
using data from the government's 40 out
of date algorithm in light of this what
is the council doing to cease any
further planning applications and
developments currently in the local plan
thank you I call upon the leader
councilor Ashby to respond thank you
thank you councilor by Edward
um the adoption the adopted local plan
including the housing crop requirements
was prepared in accordance with the
government's guidance and was agreed by
two independent inspectors
the guidance has not yet changed and
neither has the housing standard method
however the government has published and
proposed amendments to the National
policy framework and has indicated its
intention to review the standard method
in 2024 I will refer back to my my Aid
memoir
the council will be responding to the
current consultation on a key on a
number of key points which I think I
outlined earlier however even if there
were significant changes to the
government's guidance and the standard
method it will only affect the level of
housing land required in future local
plans that is it may lead to a lower
level of additional housing required as
a result of the current review which
extends the plan period to 2040.
it does not provide the opportunity to
rewrite the provisions of existing plans
in the meantime the council needs to
continue to con to consent housing on
the sites allocated in the adopted plan
which was adopted in 2020.
subject to the detailed schemes being
acceptable refusing applications on
allocated sites would likely to lead to
those consents being issued on appeal
and the significant risk significant
cost being awarded against the council
furthermore if the council were to
refuse planning commissions for schemes
on allocated sites this would undermine
the council's position in relation to
the housing delivery test and Trigger
presumptions in favor of new housing
developments
thank you very much leader councilor
Braidwood do you have a supplementary
question yes I do chair
thank you Council Ashby if the council
continues to allow developments to
Simply press on using the thought we out
of date algorithm does it accept
responsibility for the loss of some of
the best and most versatile agricultural
land for food security thank you
thank you Council leader back to you
leader do you have a response
thank you chair um well all I can do is
keep reiterating what I'm saying there
we will do everything we can to
challenge the grade one agricultural
land and
um as soon as the government come to
realize and do some joined up thinking
then hopefully we will get there but
there is very little that we can do on
the allocation prior to that but we need
to keep emphasizing but I would remind
um everybody here it's not the council
that puts the land up it is the farmers
so you know maybe some pressure on them
as well would help but
um you know there are there is a lot at
fault here but we can only carry on
campaigning for what we can do against
central government thank you
thank you very much leader agenda item
7f question number six from a member
regarding housing developments and
Southern water capacity I call upon
councilor Smith
thank you chair
and it's usually me banging on about
that the Farmland but
um
events of the last few months have
demonstrated that southern water is
currently unable to provide a reliable
supply of drinking water to homes and
businesses across thanet recent
incidents have included multiple water
outages with inadequate compensation and
scant regard for the needs of their most
vulnerable customers
does the leader agree with me that it is
irresponsible for TDC to continue to
approve any further large housing
developments in the district until
Southern water has completed upgrading
its infrastructure and is able to
demonstrate award
is able to demonstrate water supply that
is fit for purpose
thank you councilor smithsonish I'm sure
the police on a lot of people's minds I
call upon the leader councilor Ashby
foreign
popular tonight chair perhaps I'll take
you up on your offer of being the lift
attendant because I've been up and down
quite a bit tonight
so the local plan considers the issues
of water supply
throughout its development and delivery
by engaging with the relevant utility
companies specific specifically
including Southern water this engagement
provides Southern water with strategic
opportunity to consider the impact of
housing growth and water supply
in addition the water providers produce
and publish regional and local Water
Resource Management plans which
currently this does not mean focus on
the high footfalls areas of the district
sorry I've lost my
I've lost my uh train there sorry about
this
oh sorry yes so
um the water fries so as you know I sit
on the task force group and we are
endeavoring to Pathfinders possible
group and we we continue to engage with
Southern water but it is completely
outside of my remit to actually stop any
building until Southern water completely
upgrade their infrastructure I think it
would mean that we probably don't have
any building for the next 100 years but
hopefully we can push them on but the
new housing isn't as we've said in the
past the new housing isn't the issuing
planning our issue is our historical
stock the age of our stock and until
that is sorted out then we're always
going to have a problem with that but
new housing is not necessarily the
um the cause of
what happened in the outages there were
two failures at one particular pumping
station which I agree Southern water
should have better resilience in their
network
but hopefully that is all up to scratch
now and we won't experience any
instances like that again
thank you leader and yes you have been
the wars this evening Council Smith do
you have a supplementary
you seem surprised
think of something on your feet there's
an outage right now just saying
um but that was my supplementary
question and
in the context
of akaime and ecological emergency
and with the benefit
of a new planning framework
doesn't it behoove than it to lead in
these matters I I understand that my own
recent motion to demand more specific
engagement with Southern water in
helping us
to make
um
more sustainable planning decisions was
not supported by the council and and I
think I understand why
although a near identical motion was
passed in Lewis and and other councils
could I have a question please yeah yeah
yeah I'm really getting that honest
um thank you chair
um my question is
what opportunities did you perceive for
thanet to go further than other English
local authorities in policies to protect
the precious environment that sustains
our district and feeds much of the
nation
thank you councilor Smith and you were
thinking on your feet I call upon the
leader Council Ashby
well of course this is National policy
so um as much as I'd love well I
probably wouldn't love the job in number
10 but um
um or even even Secretary of State for
the environment or actually any
government position right at this moment
in time
um but it is down to the central
government and all we can do as a
council is continue to put pressure on
the government
um whichever government it may be to
actually
um
Force the the water providers to step up
to the plate
um we have read recently
um
that the government are now extending
the fines up to 250 million and I
understand that the um the national
farming unions
chief executive gave the Secretary of
State for the environment a hell of a
rough ride yesterday and virtually
reduced it to tears so that's all we can
do we can just keep keep banging on keep
campaigning
um and um I would like to add that
overview and scrutiny are going to
um
host uh
um some evidence that's coming in from
Southern water to challenge them again
so just we just got to keep challenging
them but I can't stop what's happening
because it's National policy and as much
as I'd love to I don't have that power
thank you cheer
thank you very much indeed leader gender
item 8 notice of motion no motions on
notice have been received in accordance
with Council procedure rule three
therefore I'm afraid it's back to you
leader for agenda item nine the leaders
report
[Laughter]
as my penultimate leaders report for
this term in somewhat is somewhat
shorter than usual as a good deal in my
workload has been working on the cabin
with the cabinet and officers putting
together the budget for this year
I would like to thank all members for
their scrutiny and support by voting to
agree what is an ambitious 2023-24
budget by virtue of the extra investment
in growth for service areas such as
enforcement and our property team
every year it gets harder to produce a
balanced budget for whoever is in
control so aiming for a more
self-sufficiency by increasing Revenue
growth is essential foundation for the
future of this Council
another main area my time has been
involved with is working closely with
the CMT putting together the future
delivery for the port of Ramsgate
this week members will have received a
briefing and the cabinet report
outlining outlining details of this
exciting opportunity for thanet to
reinvigorate the port and utilize more
of its potential
it is a complicated process and the
robust report outlines the models that
have been considered this is a wonderful
chance to build on the leveling up funds
and to bring future financial and
employment sustainability to the area
this month started off with more good
news for the expansion of thanet's tree
canopy with our Open Spaces team hosting
a tree planting event at Ware
recreational ground
sixth form students from Chatham and
Clarendon grammar school sorry Chatham
and Clarity grammar school volunteered
to help plant an additional 16 standard
trees to complete the 2022-23 Ramsgate
tree planting project
we have received a revised draft than
neighborhood plan for sorry we have
received a draft neighborhood plan from
broadstairs in Saint Peter's Town
Council and are now seeking views on the
proposal which is the last opportunity
to comment before the proposed plan goes
to the independent examiner which will
update the existing neighborhood plan
the six weeks consultation opened in the
9th of February and closes at 5 pm on
Thursday the 23rd of March 23.
I will finish off with the amazing story
of the Banksy artwork that appeared as
as if his way overnight as is his way
overnight on the side of a house in
Margate as you'll be aware this has
attracted worldwide audience I think
Margate is becoming more recognized in
Westminster these days
this work does of course raise the
important issue of domestic abuse and we
have been in touch with the owner of the
property to understand their intentions
around the preservation
who as this is being reported in
discussions with the Dreamland estate to
provide a solution for the future of the
work thank you chair
thank you very much leader can I just
ask a question how do we know it's a
Banksy
uh he confirmed it on his website chair
I see all right I call upon counselor on
his website I have a reason to believe
we tried climbing the fridge but I did
have the idea that maybe we should take
ownership the the fridge but I was I was
talked down on that one chair
very good very good I called upon
councilor Everett comment on or ask
questions in relation to the leaders
report
well thank you chair and this might be
the first time that the response has
been longer than the report
so I thank the leader for her report and
the advanced notice as usual and I will
say I was slightly taken aback by how
short it was
um given the last one was in early
December I thought she might have seen
the need to reference the issues with
water supply that affected residents in
broadstairs in particular but obviously
that's up to her
she refers to the budget and of course
we on this side did support the budget
because we recognize that it contains
some good things
and I have every respect for the hard
work that went into it
but given it's a 19.6 increase in
day-to-day spending I'm not sure that
she's right that things get more
difficult every year
yes inflation is running at 10 but the
council's biggest cost is its staff and
as the report suggests their pay cost is
only budgets to increase by five percent
so in fact the council is spending more
to do more including taking a million
pound from reserves despite claiming
that the 170 000 that labor wanted to
commit from reserves was somehow an
unaffordable excess
it was a shame that the conservative
group couldn't bring itself to support
that labor amendment to acknowledge the
need for more street cleaning services
and I know that it's this 11th avatory
Administration we're now getting a
public statement from the Council of
what the public should expect in this
area well better late than never
councilor bayford told us a fortnight
ago that we could do better within
existing resources if I quote him
correctly
for those that sorts begs the question
of why the administration hadn't done
better already
now I see there's a conservative leaflet
in Beacon Road Ward saying that the
candidate will Lobby for a street
cleaner for every Ward
and yet strangely the same member voted
against extra street cleaners a
fortnight ago
so presumably under this master plan a
one member world will have the same
Resource as a three-member ward but I'm
sure councilor bayford wouldn't want
that or perhaps he would
moving on to the plans for Ramsgate Port
I find myself in Broad agreement with
the proposals going to Cabinet next week
which is probably not surprising given
it was Labor's leveling up plan in the
first place
but a good idea is a good idea wherever
it comes from just like spending the new
homes bonus on our own temporary
accommodation
once again over we find a Conservative
candidate in Ramsgate pushing a
completely different idea for the pool
he wants to build I think 1500 homes on
it
now I'm not sure if this is a
conservative election strategy to take
up several contradictory positions at
once in the hope of confusing the
opposition a tactic more normally found
with the liberal Democrats
worthy of the Blackadder scriptwriters
or perhaps the conservative party is
just falling apart locally as well as it
is nationally I don't know if you can
help on that one sir or possibly Vice
chair
on a serious note the public does expect
important decisions like these about the
pool to be taken in public by elected
members whoever they may be after the
election and I hope cabinet will bear
that in mind next week
so finally we come to the Hokey Cokey
story
the Banksy freezer in Margate
she brought the old freezer in she put
the old freezer out but it was the
council's reputation that was shaken all
about
on this one the leader does have more
sympathy Public Safety must be the
council's primary concern and if I have
a criticism is that the leader was a bit
slow to communicate what the council was
doing and why and it did look from the
outside anyway as if the leader didn't
know
but I'm sure it's an episode that the
leader won't forget in a hurry and there
is that she's alluded to a serious side
to the issue in highlighting domestic
abuse which is not subject for hilarity
I will say that I'm very happy that the
problem arose on her watch and not mine
but at least it was a light-hearted
episode that has had a happy ending and
I'm sure that we could both share a
smile over it now thank you Jeff
well councilor Everett sir I'm just
going to take a moment out to say I
thoroughly enjoyed that and I think we
all did I just wish you'd been like that
for most of my time as chair we'd have
had some very enjoyable evenings and yes
by the way the vice chair and myself
have had enough of all of it
on the leader to respond
I'm actually seriously thinking of
forming a new group for Council we've
all seriously had enough of it all group
no
um on a on a serious note regarding the
budget yes I do thank you and um it will
it does get harder but hopefully we've
set a budget that might make it a tad
easier if we have some independent
Revenue coming in because we can't as
you quite rightly say on numerous
occasions we can't rely on central
government anymore and I I've accepted
that and tried to find a way forward on
the port
um yes is good news
um but a cunning plan was hatched by
Baldrick I think at one point and um it
is unfortunate that uh
what was that Baldrick
well as long as um
as long as um we can end up delivering
the right results then I'm sure that we
can all afford to rejoice in it at that
point
um I can't control
um
I can't control the cats out there on
what they want to say to the Press prior
to election but obviously following that
then it might be a bit easier
um Banksy yes we've had up and down up
and down and now we've got the in and
out in and out I think I've covered
probably the whole of Strictly Come
Dancing tonight so um
um I I'm surprised um that you know
obviously you didn't you didn't know
about it prior to me um because there
were quite a lot of Labor supporters
down there with cameras and I think at
one point one of the KCC labor councils
did ask for my resignation to which I
thought well
does he want me to resign because he
doesn't like the look of the Banksy but
I I really don't know but anyway I'm
surprised that you didn't know quicker
than me but um that is what happens in
news spreads a lot quicker than maybe
some of the comms but I think we should
take the good bit out of this and
hopefully it will provide some rip
e it will provide some visitors which
will bring valuable Revenue into our
economy thank you chair thank you very
much leader I call upon councilor Garner
are you going to entertain us as well
councilor Garner
well I think I can assure you that I
won't be reaching the same levels of
brevity as as Council Everett in this in
this response although I'll shall do my
best at some point
um I'd like to start by reiterating our
thanks for the hard work which went into
the budget uh from both officers and
cabinet members we think it's basically
sound although as councilors Austin and
Wing expressed at the budget meeting we
remain concerned about the plans for the
port
uh we do thank officers for the briefing
they gave us on Monday on the future
delivery of the port of Ramsgate paper
which was issued on on Tuesday and you
won't be surprised to hear that we are
reading that with interest and we'll be
at cabinet on the 4th of March to give
you our full response
in the meantime
while we remain we've remained puzzled
as to why we're going back into the
Volvo when other ports are cutting in
Services due to lack of demand we do
agree with officers that job creation at
the Port is very important for panic and
believe that with a really
forward-looking part of the plan is the
Green campus and we're concerned that
it's in danger of being squeezed into
very little space with limited scope for
expansion
when this offers our best opportunity to
train our adults and young people for
the jobs of the future
we will be asking questions about the
fisheries and shipbuilding side of the
proposal as we believe it's important to
preserve and support both of these
businesses not only for their intrinsic
value but also because they have great
interest to visitors
we will also be expressing our concerns
about Brett's plans for expansion and
the surprise that having only just
provided them with a new birth with
massively greater capacity than the old
one further expansion plans are being
proposed on the back of a phone call
between them and us we'd have expected
intensive negotiation to have taken
place from the moment we we proposed
replacing the births last year
on top of these and any other questions
our key in concern would be any proposal
to delegate decisions to officers we've
all worked hard over the last year or so
especially you leader to rest back
control and make sure we are not
excluded from information and decision
making as we approach a local election
we believe it is important that this and
any other future cabinet steps up and
takes control of this and other projects
our open green spaces are under constant
threat from development and having a
robust neighborhood plan is a useful
level of protection against this
when a couple of those green spaces were
recently sold on the Wimpy estate the
fact that they were designated as such
in the broadstairs and Peter's plan
helped enable the planning application
to build on one of them to be refused
with the latest iteration of this plan
now out for review I would encourage all
residents of broadstairs to engage in
the consultation process and also
recommend it as a decent example of a
plan to be used by any current or future
town councils in the area
related to this we believe a closer
mutually respectful and supportive
working relationship with town and
parish councils is going to be
increasingly important for us all
so we are looking forward to the
publication of the overview and scrutiny
committees town and Parish council's
working part of your port and hope the
working party's recommendations will be
implemented
another element of protection which has
so far proved valuable to protect green
spaces are the tree protection orders
placed on the trees on the Wimpy estate
when the land was sold
so while of course it's great to hear
about all the tree planting across the
district especially the planting
involving sick form students from
Chatham and Clarendon Grammar School
these and all other existing trees in
thanet need to be given as much
protection as possible and we would like
to see a change of emphasis in tpos
which makes it easier for them to be
applied
finally Banks's latest creation on the
side of the house in Margate
as has been said it's brought a lot of
attention to the district and more
importantly to the issue it highlights
the continuing scourge of domestic abuse
we're pleased that the Oasis domestic
abuse service charity will be benefiting
from its sale
and temporary rehousing in Dreamland
they've done an excellent to job
supporting survivors of domestic abuse
for nearly 30 years and unfortunately
their services needed more and more the
number of victims has risen as writers
themselves said until we live in a world
free of abuse they and other groups will
continue to fight this issue and do all
they can to support survivors it's an
issue we should all be fighting
and of course we should all be
supporting thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Garner I call upon the leader councilor
Ashby thank you chair thank you Donna
um support well obviously that's the
whole point of issuing the report so
everyone's got time to examine it
um and then I look forward to the
questions that uh under 20.1 that no
doubt will be coming our way um next
Thursday I mean it is important that we
all look at this but I will emphasize
again that this Council needs to
make our assets work for us and this is
a prime example which hasn't been
working for us
and we need to turn that round
if at the in the event that following
the um
well I think it's a bit of a it's a it's
a weird thing but um it's a sort of
reverse
um
purchase process but it's something that
needs to travel correctly through the
process and if at the event of that we
end up with no interested parties then
you will be proved right that there
isn't the facility there and if they're
queuing up to come in then I will be
right
um so I hope that the the
um industry advice that we've been given
which has been extensive from people
that actually know about this stuff
actually it is there and I hope that it
turns around the fortunes because if
if we actually make some Revenue out of
the port then we can probably have a
straight cleaner in every walled chair
um
but no but
but you know the the point is again that
a decision needed to be made I've made
the decision be it right or wrong but at
least it's a decision we will see the
proof will be in the pudding
one of us has got to be right and one of
us has got to be wrong but
um I just hope it's me but it won't be
done in an instant these things take
time
councils have to go through the due
process obviously
and we hope that it doesn't
attract the the negative attention it
needs to attract positive attention but
um I can assure you
um there are a few eyes already looking
so hopefully we can put to bed a good
concession that brings us some
prosperity to the whole of the district
the neighborhood oh you want to sit down
now the neighborhoods plan is exactly
what they're there for and um you're
quite right they are there to protect
and to be specific about certain areas
and um it is important that people
engage within the consultation process
that is what they're meant for
and yes the Oasis
um extremely important work that they do
and I wish that we we didn't have to
have the requirement of this type of
organization but unfortunately
um
they've been around for a long time and
sadly I think they'll be around for long
a lot longer but all we can do is do
everything we can to support them thank
you chair
thank you very much indeed leader I call
upon councilor Reverend Stuart Piper to
comment on or question ask questions in
relation to the leaders report
thank you Mr chairman thank you leader
for your report I will try and make my
response shorter than your reports that
we uh than your report was
uh thank you also to the team for
putting the budget together I would just
like to say on the record that uh I was
very disappointed not to be able to vote
on the budget and support all the effort
had been made it was due to the fact
that an interest had to be declared on
the overview and scrutiny panel and I
have asked that we can look at this
because I think members of the overview
and scrutiny panel challenging things
like this may be disenfranchised in the
future I would hope not but that's why I
was unable to vote on it
the port was mentioned at Ramsgate Town
Council last night and those present and
our listeners to the webcast were
advised that details were and would
continue to be available through TDC
communication systems as things progress
and we can only encourage people to get
involved and to read up as much as they
can about it
a draft neighborhood planned marvelous
that's something we've been looking for
in Ramsgate for nearly 10 years now and
the only thing I can say is two two
things really one I'm embarrassed that
we still haven't got one and two aren't
delighted it's not the responsibility of
Ramsgate Town Council it's the
responsibility of the people putting the
plan together we hope they'll come up
with something soon
well now Banksy I'm still not sure
leader whether Banksy was highlighting
the problem or suggesting a solution
with half a body hanging out of the deep
freeze it did cause me to wonder but
then I suppose that's the nature of true
art isn't it one man's unmade bed is
another man's well you decide thank you
later
thank you very much indeed councilor
puppy you're referencing two artists
there I presume
over to your leader
thank you chair
uh
well we start with
a down there with with the return of the
freezer after it had been made safe
um I was greeted with quite a lot of uh
photography going on and I did actually
do a bit of a poses as to uh diving in
the in the freezer myself but um and I
with a little quip that most people in
town it would probably like to see me
put in the freezer but uh no it was
light-hearted there was there was some
how can I say there was an unpleasant
exchanges which I I think was very very
unfairly pointed at the council we do
have a duty of care and we carried out
what was believed to be correct and in
the end all's well ends well I think and
um I'm glad that it's found the home
or eventually we'll find a home in
Dreamland where other people will have
the opportunity to come and see it
um on the budget voting um we did
actually have a conversation with the
chief executive today because obviously
you couldn't vote there was also a
member of my group that couldn't vote
and there was a member of the green
though party that couldn't vote so
although it was a bit bizarre and I can
understand the process through it but we
have agreed to have a look at that part
of the Constitution because it does seem
a bit silly that Maine councilors can't
vote on the budget because I mean if we
take it to the extreme maybe I shouldn't
have voted because I actually put two
pounds in the parking meter when I come
when I go down into the old town and
when I go into Ramsgate so in the
because I part where I'm not getting a
free pass on so um I think that will be
looked at and uh that's on the list
certainly to be reviewed
um and thank you for for your support on
that and um
the port well I can only guess at your
stance on the port but um uh I assume
that you would also like to see some
ferries coming in and out of the port
and uh bring back some
even if it's a visual Joy
um to people the residents of thanet
then I believe it will will do that
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed leader
gender item 10 it sees back to you
councilor Piper for a report from the
chairman of the overview and scrutiny
panel
thank you very much again Mr chairman um
members there are uh four currently
ongoing
um scrutiny review topics that you can
see in the report that you have between
you this evening most of them are coming
to a close now
um but the one I would particularly uh
like to mention is the now long running
memorials plaques and monuments we are
uh I'm told in possession of better
government advice and what to do with it
our monitoring office has been producing
the report ready for us and we hope to
report back very soon but those four are
there for you to see there's been a
couple of mentions of the Southern water
situation uh this evening so it beholds
me to tell you the letter has been sent
they have been written to and invited to
attend our meeting in March I hope you
won't mind me mentioning him but
councilor Curry has already written to
me with a question for southern water
and as much as I may be able to do on
that evening to to chair that meeting
and field your questions can you get
them to me as soon as possible that way
we can give preparation to Southern
water so they can make their
presentation relevant to the concerns we
have but that doesn't mean I'm trying to
give them an easy ride it simply means
if you suddenly turn up that evening and
a certain amount of allocated time has
been given to this presentation and
we've got 48 questions we know nothing
about and they know nothing about they
might just say well I'm sorry I can't
give you that detail at the moment I'll
write to you later we don't want those
kind of answers we want proper answers
so if I can commend that March meeting
to you and as far as this report is
concerned members I commend it to you
thank you very much to the officers who
support us as always as we put these
meetings together
thank you very much indeed Council Piper
and that does make good sense everything
you had to say do members have any
comments
Elsa Ghana
Q yeah I'd just like to ask for a little
bit of clarity please
um councilor pipe about the southern
water invitation you mentioned I've been
invited
um have you had any indication whether
they're going to attend you any reply
and how long are you gonna how long are
we gonna give them to give you a reply
before we start chasing them up because
I wouldn't like to sort of get to the
middle of March for that meeting and
they don't turn up thank you thank you
councilor Piper thank you chairman uh
thank you Council Garner yes we we have
written to them and invited them to
attend March it was commented at the
time that that might be a bit soon to
get them here but that's what we went
for I'm hoping we will get a response uh
indicating their attendance but if not
we still have April
as as a full-back position but ideally
we would like them in March and we would
like some information sooner rather than
later
thank you
thank you councilor Piper I have
councilor Yates for you as well
thank you um chair and thank you Council
Piper um just one question about the
public attendance the ovian scrutiny
meeting I believe the public can attend
and they can ask questions can you
explain what the process is for the
public members members of the public
being able to ask questions about
meeting thanks
councilor Piper
thank you Chan yes I believe the public
can ask questions uh the exact process I
would like to defer to Mr Hughes who
would be able to perhaps give us the
exact
process by which those questions can be
asked I understand it's easier obviously
for counselors to get questions in
earlier might not be quite so easy for
members of the public so perhaps Mr
Hughes if you wouldn't mind uh helping
us out here with just a little bit of
clarification on that please
thank you councilor Piper I'm sure
councilor Mr Hughes will look into it as
to whether he's in a position to answer
right now I'm uncertain
perhaps we might would you rather leave
it to uh
sorry
yeah
so um ideally although it is in the
discretion of the chairman of the
ovarian scrutiny panel ideally we would
like members of the public to write to
us in advance to declare the fact that
they wish to ask a question
um we allocate a total of six minutes it
doesn't sound a great deal for public
speaking for each item on the agenda so
for the
um this item for southern water there
will be uh
six minutes of public speaking and
there's a maximum of two people per for
that item
well thank you for that Mr Hughes I
thought that was brilliant on the roof
counselor Everett
well I'm grateful for Mr Hughes uh
clarifying that I I would just say that
I hope on this occasion the chair would
exercise some discretion over that
because I think the public might feel if
they were only allowed six minutes on
this particular item that they were
really being sidelined but I'm sure that
councilor Piper will give back to you
consideration thank you
thank you councilor Everett and I know
councilor Piper to be a good generous
chairman in this respect councilor Piper
you don't need to say thanks for that
chair
yes I think it is it is clearly a very
important as well as contentious
subjects and my aim would be to be as
Fair as we possibly can one thing I
would like to avoid is the same question
being asked several different ways we
need to be sensible if the meat of a
question has been asked and answered
then maybe I'll be a little bit quicker
with the moving along uh but it is my
intention to give members of the public
and of this Council a fair chance to air
their concerns but first of course we
need to hear what we're being presented
with
so the other says yes but no tautology
we shall move on to a gender item 11.
council tax setting
I would advise an accordion Council
procedure rule 17.6 I will call for a
recorded vote on the motion or any
Amendment and substantive motions
therein I call upon councilor David
Saunders at this point
thank you chairman
this report enables the council to set
the council tax for the year
2023-24 for each part of its area after
taking into account the precepts of the
Kent County Council Ken police and crime
commissioner and Kent and Medway fire
and rescue service
chairman
I reck I commend the report support the
report and await the results of the
recorded vote thank you
thank you councilor Saunders Do you have
a seconder
councilor Ashby
we'll now begin a recorded vote
conducted by the monitoring officer
thank you chair
the names are already not got hand up
cheers
that's a paper I didn't see you there do
you want to jump in quickly I'm sorry to
interrupt the process
the council just Clarity really the the
precept is set based on the money the
needs to cancel needs to raise in order
to carry out its business that includes
the fees and charges element of the
budget that was set before which I was
unable to vote on therefore not able to
vote on the budget how do I stand about
voting for this evening
am I given is are we all given free
dispensation to vote on this subject and
separate it from the previous two
thank you councilor Piper um I
understand it's fine but uh
Samir
yeah it should be okay too for everybody
to vote it doesn't apply council tax is
different to the budget itself so you
should be okay to vote
okay thank you very much I'll read the
in the alphabetical order you're voting
for against or abstain
[Music]
Alban four
councilor Ashby for councilor Austin
councilor Bailey
councilor Jill bayford
Council Robert bayford councilor Boyd
councilor Braidwood
councilor Crittenden
councilor Curry
counselor Dennis
counselor Dexter
councilor Duckworth
councilor Everett
councilor fellows
councilor Garner
councilor Hart or councilor Huxley
counselor Keane counselor cup
Council lace
councilor Pat Moore
councilor avondin
councilor Parsons
Council Linda Piper
Professor Stewart Piper
Council pew
Council Vatican
Council of rose
Castle Rogers
concert David Saunders
councilor Maeve Saunders councilor
Savage for Casa scoby or counselor Scott
foreign
Smith
cancer Tomlinson
cancer violin
councilor Whitehead
counselor wing
councilor right
and finally Council Yates
that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed members
gender item 12. members allowances
scheme for 2023 2024 I move that the
recommendation is set out in the report
be adopted with the vice chair please
second second lecture do members agree
thank you agenda item 13. oh did I
who was the captain
for Austin I didn't see you uh thank you
chair I just wanted to point out at the
risk of being a groundhog day person
that um we still have chairman and so on
in the listings here of allowances and
we did agree that we would change that
so could we commend that to officers to
make those changes thank you
thanks
thank you councilor Austin that is noted
I don't think there's any disrespect
intended though it's an oversight
uh therefore our back where was I now I
generate some 12 yes do members agree
yes we agreed yes agenda item 13
creation of an appointment subcommittee
I move that the recommendation is set
out in the report be adopted with the
vice chairman please second second that
chair do members agree
thank you gender item 14 calendar of
meetings for 2023 2025 I move the
recommendation of set out in the report
be adopted with the vice chairman please
second second nature do members agree
thank you
gender item 15 changes committees panels
and boards for 2022 2023
oh gosh I've got to read all this
all right that's good stuff propose
proportionality I am pleased to say that
consensus among group leaders has been
achieved and so therefore I move that
Council approves the proportionality
between groups for Community for
committee committees panels and boards
are shown in the report with the vice
chair please second second lecture two
members agreed
thank you
nomination of members to serve on
committees group leaders may take this
opportunity to advise of changes to
their nominations to committees panels
and boards for the remainder of
2022-2023 council Ashby do you wish to
advise of any nomination changes yes
please chair
some Council
home I am putting councilor towning on
planning thank you chair
thank you leader councilor Everett do
you wish to advise venue nomination
change I do chair and in so doing I'd
like to thank councilor Hopkinson for
his service to the labor group
um right licensing board councilor scoby
has kindly agreed to fall upon his sword
um removing one member uh governance and
Order councilor Yates will replace
councilor Hopkinson
the Constitution review working panel
councilor Curry will replace
councilor Hopkinson and the appointments
panel
um councilor Everett will take that seat
he's very keen isn't he councilor Garner
oh sorry
sorry chair I leader
councilman just reminded me um on the
appointment of the appointments
committee I would nominate myself to sit
on that panel
forgive me for forgetting that bit no
it's perfectly all right I mean we put
things to right so that's good you can
face each other across the Battle Zone
[Music]
all right all right uh councilor Garner
do you wish advice of any nomination
changes yeah thank you
um chair
so on the governance and audit committee
where we now have an extra Place
councilor Austin will be joining myself
on that committee and on the
appointments committee councilor Austin
will be joining Council councilors
Everett and Ashby in making appointments
thank you thank you councilor Garner
councilor Piper
thank you Mr chairman um councilor Linda
Piper will pick up the additional seat
on overview and scrutiny councilor John
Dennis on licensing and the changes I'd
like to welcome councilor David Wallin
to the group and he will take the seat
on planning and constitutional review
working party thank you thank you very
much indeed councilor Piper
members that concludes the business for
the meeting of the council this evening
thank you very much indeed for your
attendance